If you've been wondering where
two of the most famous sisters
in the world have been since they
stopped making movies together,
you're probably not alone. Here's why you don't
hear very much about the Olsen twins anymore.
If you grew up watching Full House, you're
definitely familiar with the Olsen twins'
first big role, but you might not realize just
how young they were when they got started.
After both Mary-Kate and Ashley were cast
to play the family's most adorable member,
Michelle, at just six months
old, they became stars thanks
to the show's enduring popularity and
overwhelming affection for the character.
"I've been on Full House forever."
However, since the twins started
so young, they didn't really get
to choose their careers. Full House was a
great opportunity for Mary-Kate and Ashley,
but it makes sense that they eventually
retired in favor of other pursuits.
Whether or not Mary-Kate and Ashley got the
chance to choose their childhood profession,
there's no denying that their tenure
as actresses was insanely lucrative.
"My favorite thing is eating a cake."
After they got older, Mary-Kate and Ashley
launched Dualstar Entertainment, spawning a
fan club that served as a subscription site and as
the backbone to the twins' growing media empire.
In 2007, the Olsens even joined
powerhouses like talk show host
Oprah Winfrey on the Forbes ranking of
the wealthiest women in entertainment,
with the publication estimating their net wealth
at $100 million and noting that Dualstar sold,
quote, "$1 billion worth of merchandise
worldwide in a year–everything from videos
to hair-care products." At the time, the twins
were just 20 years old. Making their fortune
at a seriously young age enabled them to
step out of the limelight fairly early.
It might seem a little crazy that Mary-Kate and
Ashley were raking in literal billions before
they could legally drink, but when you consider
just how hard the twins worked throughout their
acting career, you'll understand why. After Full
House, the two embarked on a series of features,
television films, and direct-to-video
releases throughout the 1990s. All told,
the twins appeared in 27
projects between 1992 and 2004.
However, 2004 brought an end to their
joint acting careers with New York Minute,
their second theatrical release.
Ultimately, the film performed poorly,
both critically and commercially -
having one of the lowest openings of
all time - which wasn't exactly a favorable
conclusion to the girls' acting career.
The Olsens were two of the most famous young
women in the world throughout their childhood
and adolescence. However, it should come as
no surprise that this fame came with some
serious drawbacks - specifically,
some very gross objectification.
In June of 2019, writer Yomi Adegoke penned
a piece about men in dark corners of the
internet who, quote, "count down" until
young women turn 18 and become "legal,"
mentioning the Olsen twins as an example.
Mary-Kate and Ashley had grown up on camera,
from their casting in Full House at just
six months old onward. Adegoke wrote,
"Men patiently waiting until they hit puberty,
and their fantasies made the switch from
perverse to pedestrian, made me feel queasy."
Adegoke spends the rest of her essay detailing the
seriously damaging implications of this
upsetting trend, which was potentially
harmful to the Olsens and may have played
a role in their decision to leave acting.
In the years since New York Minute flopped at
the box office, the Olsens have found solace
and success in an entirely new venture
in the world of high fashion. In 2006,
the twins launched The Row. The brand was the
result of Ashley's goal to create the perfect
white t-shirt. However, the two preferred
to let the clothes speak for themselves,
and didn't even do a public interview about
The Row for several years after its debut.
"It's not a trend-based brand. It's really about
what these women want to be wearing every day."
The Row - which the Olsens still own and manage
alongside lines like Elizabeth & James, a
concept named for their siblings - has won several
awards. It even took home the highest honor of the
Council of the Fashion Designers of America, the
Womenswear Designer of the Year Award, two years
in a row. In 2018, the Olsens announced that
the Row would launch a menswear line, complete
with knits, suits, and denim. Why return to acting
when you've got a successful fashion collection?
In the absence of their acting career, both
Mary-Kate and Ashley have been pretty focused
on becoming fashion mavens. However, throughout
the years, Mary-Kate has struck out on her own
to debut a talent that she doesn't seem
to share with her twin: horseback riding.
According to PopSugar, Mary-Kate
was spotted in September of 2016
competing in the annual American Gold Cup,
which is held at the Old Salem Farm in New
York. The publication reported that Mary-Kate
rode three different horses during the event,
which is considered one of the most renowned
show jumping events in the world. By that point,
Mary-Kate had been riding horses competitively
for three years and had been photographed riding
recreationally in places like the Hamptons.
It seems like this hobby holds more interest
for Mary-Kate than acting, and she's clearly
talented if she made it into this famous event.
Though it might seem like the Olsens
do just about everything together,
you might not realize that after
one twin stopped acting entirely,
the other stayed on screen for just a little
while longer. After Ashley stopped acting,
Mary-Kate continued, appearing in projects
like the critically panned 2011 film Beastly.
However, in 2012, the twins told Elle UK that they
were out of the game for good.
As Mary-Kate told the magazine,
"It just felt right to move
away [from the spotlight]."
Meanwhile, Ashley said,
"I don't have to be a pretty face. I've
done that, but now it's important and
liberating to be on the other side of the lens. I
don't like to be the center of attention anymore."
She added that she's still
interested in Hollywood,
but that if she ever returned, it wouldn't
be as an actress. The two clearly found
their bliss elsewhere — and with
each other. Mary-Kate told Elle,
"Nothing would ever split us up.
Separate side projects are one thing,
but we work better as a team."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.